where is football where is football
season because this is what for I need
it I need it I need it I need football
soon as basketball ends I need football
like I would watch
I would watch I would watch football
players play football with a basketball
right now I would watch them play it
with a basketball just even for a couple
months until we can get a regular ball
on the field that's there should be a
sport in the in-between them where they
have football players playing football
with them with the basketball so well I
should've never opened my mouth today
let's go
[Music]
and it must be
my bones babyhood is gonna change
little time for me to set that parking
brake
[Music]
come on let it out the song I would sing
it just for you oh you know we've heard
that song so much and sometimes in the
beginning honest I love the song and
sometimes I'm beginning I hate it but
then when it gets to that party just
when it gets that shine it just it kind
of just squeezes the fun out of me it
forces it forces the fun right out of me
and I you know I am I am somebody that
has to have the fun forced out of them
I didn't even like it when people would
tickle me
Hicklin let's say that's just I mean
that's body wizardry somebody going just
hanging it yeah and you just you and him
and then you'll just laugh
uncontrollably sheer just somebody just
just just playing you joy just playing
that the the the joyous those joyous
elements somebody just wiggling your
little joy segments inside of you and
you remember when you get tickled and
I'm like getting tickled was crazy
before you started doing sex it's are
your you know self pleasure herself
touch tickling that was like it really
kind of was the closest thing if
somebody tickle you it was like their
closest and you didn't know it yet cuz
you were young but you know if I look
back through my feelings you know if you
really go back it's that tickling
sneezing is one where you get like a you
know where your body just has that
rudimentary expulsion of just joy and
then full-on later on in life full-on
you know it yeah cue lashing our human
body you know that full-body Combe you
feel me but yeah remember that when
somebody would tickle you you put in
control it's like if somebody just
hooked some jumper cables off of a damn
Buick just right up to your rib meat and
just shook yeah that was always and and
not if I was in a bad mood sometimes I
remember my dad would tickle me
and he wasn't like my dad he only had
nine fingers so something happened to
one of his fingers and and then he had
nine of them and uh because you don't
need you don't need ten fingers let's be
honest about that let's be on us right
now we have you know most people have
ten and shout out to everybody with less
you know but you don't need ten finger
brother look at this the one next to the
pinky game they win nothing with that
bad boy people a lot of people don't
even get married anymore you could give
that one you know that could be a donate
that to somebody they make a little
wiener for him you know if somebody in a
lot of countries if somebody doesn't
have a wiener they will use if somebody
else's finger and make that and make
that wiener that's why sometimes in like
like third-world countries you come out
of a coma or something and you got a new
wiener on and it'll have a dam a
marriage band on it you're like what at
least take the take the jewelry off
before you put on my new my new low body
digit but my dad only had nine on him he
was running on nine and he would tickle
me and I and and it was only when I was
feeling bad he would tickle me and he
wanted to make me feel better you know
and if you're a senior citizen it's hard
to make a little baby feel that good and
you almost really have to tickle them
but well my dad would tickle me only at
night and he'd always be like I can't
tickle you that good I only got nine
fingers and he would tickle me and but
I've always been that person you got to
force the fun out of me a lot of times
you know there's something inside of me
sometimes where it's like I don't want
to have that much fun like I want to but
I don't want to admit it
no it's like if I see somebody really
feeling joy or dance and I get I just
have this anxiety this insecurity this
I'd almost you know sometimes I'd almost
rather just stay on the side and be you
know judge the situation because if I
can judge something that keeps me out of
it
you know if I can judge something that
really it keeps me it keeps me out of it
like I hate to like admit that I like
certain things because I don't want to
be in a I just want to be by myself
sometimes inside I'll do things you know
go places and spend time with people but
sometimes there's a part of me inside of
me that wants to just be that just wants
to be by itself and say yeah then that's
up you got to squeeze the fun out of
that part of me I'm like that tuba
toothpaste and that thing is you got it
and then finally I hate to admit that
I'm having fun sometimes there's just I
just you know I am having fun but I have
a man I'll be damned if I'm gonna admit
it because if I admit that I'm having a
good time then that means that you that
we're both having a good time and it
just makes me feel and if we're
good time then let me think about this
if you know that I'm having a good time
then I guess part of me feels like maybe
you're gonna take advantage of me in
some way not like sexually or nothing
but if you know that I'm having fun or
if I let you know I'm having fun or that
I'm experienced enjoy then you're gonna
see a part of me that I don't want you
to see like if I'll let you see me
having fun in it then somehow that makes
me it's like a weakness or something
it's almost like you called me without
my shield and without my sword and then
and if that's the case if I don't have
those things then you might just even be
out you might be able to reach me you
know you might be able to reach me if I
don't have up my my judgment in my in my
joy in my you know my face that's kind
of like huh yeah they're having fun but
I'm okay right here and I just wish
sometimes it that the inside of me could
just behave the way that it's always
wanted to
you know but instead
a lot of times in my life I've been like
that don't tickle me don't tickle me and
people like why and the truth why
because I'm gonna feel good that's why
and somewhere inside of me I'm so used
to not feeling good that I'm afraid to
even go there I don't know I've just
been
a lot about I mean to divulge in all
this kind of stuff but I just you know
I've been thinking a lot I was talking a
couple weeks ago and a lot of people
were responding a you know where we were
all talking a couple weeks ago about
like relying on others you know I don't
like to rely on other people
you know for me that makes me feel weak
if I rely on others you know if I rely
on somebody if I let somebody know that
I'm dependent on them then man it just
feels like a scary place to be because
if I'm dependent on somebody man
it just feels man it feels - heck it
feels too heavy for me to do that if I'm
not depending on somebody then no matter
what happens it's all it's you know then
I you know I I don't know I can't
explain exactly what I'm trying to say
but but but
but I'll keep trying to think about it
and ruminate on it on my saw on the side
um when I'm on the sidelines I just got
home though and I'm happy to be home and
it's nice we got some new paint in the
studio so we got some nice baby kind of
at like a baby blue paint in here and a
strong baby blue not one of these you
know these weak-ass babies you see some
babies they don't even you know they got
a crawl I saw a baby a couple months ago
he was crawling he had training wheels
out coming out of it you know on the
outside of his knees do what the hell
your baby can't even crawl over there I
grew up crawling in Louisiana brush
chasing up shrimp in the yard but well
we grew up really really in a rural area
too had ground shrimp you'll see a
ground shrimp a little family of ground
shrimp headed they got on bathing suits
they headed to the beach had never even
been in the water you see a group of
them daddy got a big you know thing on
his back of our luggage yeah you know
they got a lot of weak-ass babies too
you see a baby out here they got up they
I saw a baby the other day they gave a
baby arm this baby had a had a rattle
that arm it was like it had a what was
that on it it [ __ ] I can't even think of
it man [ __ ] that baby whatever man
but they yet my dad used to tickle me
when I was young and it was fun and it
was away you know you just had to force
it out him you had to force me to have
fun you had to squeeze I was that you
had to squeeze really had to push me to
get the fun out of me and I wanted to
have fun but I just couldn't I just was
afraid I was just afraid to really just
have fun
I just really was afraid of that let's
go back from Canada and you know Canada
and I want to say congratulations to the
NBA champion dang it what they call the
damn police on myself but Toronto
Raptors the Toronto Raptors they won did
you see that and I loved it you know I
love it when the underdog wins I don't
care who it is
you know I love it when the underdog way
if a one-legged guy wins a damn a rifle
I'll stand up and [ __ ] cry bro cuz
you know me I'll sit down and cry all
day he'll you've seen the podcast but uh
but if a one-legged guy wins a raffle I
will stand up and cry you know I just
love an underdog I love an underdog if
somebody's digging a hole in their yard
to do flowers and they find somebody
that's been under there for two you know
two months or whatever barely breathing
you know through to you know somebody's
still alive I [ __ ] I love it like
damn that guy nobody first of all nobody
knew he was a or second of all he's
still alive that's beautiful I love an
underdog and the Toronto Raptors were
the underdog people could say they're
not they're not this I don't like these
mega teams the NBA got these mega teams
and four or five stars getting together
I'd go for the underdog I'm that Jimmy
Chitwood
I like that movie Hoosiers you know I
like the underdog you know if they got a
uh Aswang contest of four swans I [ __ ]
put four dollars on the back I put four
dollars on a vampire bat in a swan
contest they say get you get out put a
little bit of lipstick on that vampire
bat and you get out there and you give
them bad bird [ __ ] hell cuz that's
that's just that's just in me I love it
I love the underdog and the Toronto
Raptors already not that I feel like we
should all feel inspired by them you
know just cuz nobody expected them to
win and people could say yeah well
Golden State was missing certain players
and stuff that's fine Golden State is an
all-star team they have five all-stars
and I just loved it man I loved seeing
them and also it's nice to see but
Canada win the NBA champ
this isn't even their sport that's like
us going up to Canada with a couple of
um you know a couple Rottweilers and
winning a damn I did a rod you got those
regular iditarod them direwolf's out
there and that's like us coming up there
with a couple of Rottweilers and big
Loni you know fat Loni who's always
running out breeding these dogs
illegally and getting them out there you
got all the Rottweilers they're wearing
Patagonia coats and they imagine they go
up to Canada or Alaska and they win it
that's what that's like winning
something off your beaten path when it's
something I don't expect you to win and
that's how I you know I just it was just
great to see man congratulations to them
and it's just inspiring now any other
team that's like a middle of the pack
kind of team or you know a team that
thinks oh I don't think we could do it
next year they're gonna think they could
do it
you know and that's just man the power
of thinking that you can do something or
it's a powerful it's powerful power yes
thank you so much so to everybody man
dude it was crazy and I'll say this I'll
say this um getting into Canada is the
hardest country to get into in the
entire world Canada they don't I mean
they're they ask you like right when you
get up to the customs - they ask you
like a trick question when was the last
time you've been in the sand I got
cocaine in my pocket you know do your
answer you won't even you'll never have
even used cocaine you'll just uh yes sir
Bienvenue when was the last time that
you saw a Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone
you're like my sister's a lesbian I mean
you'll say shilling you know what the
hell is going on you know like um like
okay oh thank you what brings you to
Canada today business pleasure
prostitution and you're like I'm
allergic to apple sauce I mean dude they
put you on that hot seat how many times
have you touched yourself in the last
month like in the guys like I need to
know an answer like I'm still Cal but
the data it's like going ahead it's like
the pearly gates I mean a lot of have it
the book of you know well some of the
Bible could have been written about
Canada you know you go up the bright
light there's gates you know not sure if
everybody's getting in
I mean we could be talking we you know
is st. Peters and a customs outfit I
mean the st. Peter work at customs
because the pearly gates could be right
up there off of one of those toll roads
headed right into Canada went to
Vancouver and then came down and went to
Seattle
dude that show was fought your fire and
it was so great man oh and trick lung
Mickey came out too I think we'll try to
put a picture I'm in on the YouTube
trick long Mickey came out and he was
doing great man he looked good he looked
like one of the people from the
outsiders and so is it beautiful to have
him around and and yeah just a lot of
good people and I want to thank
everybody from the patreon who supported
we did we gave away this weekend we gave
away I want to say almost almost maybe
four thousand dollars to single dads and
we and that's cool man you know and I'm
not saying we're cool or anything like
that but it's cool it's cool that we
thought about them and that we did it
and so I just want to thank everybody
anybody that listens to this podcast
anybody you know that that's what we put
some of our earnings towards and it was
just exciting man we you know and a lot
of single dads came out and and if
you're on the YouTube right now there's
there should be some pictures and stuff
of them so you can see them and I just
want to say thank you to all the men
that came out you know we talk a lot
about single moms and stuff on here and
and because a Father's Day we wanted to
think about that and and you know it had
me thinking I was writing out some just
some cards to some of these dads and
just saying you know just trying to just
say you know happy Father's Day and
stuff and
and it had me thinking like you know my
father's you know deceased when I was 16
and there's a lot of people you know
that have lost their fathers and never
even met their fathers but it's funny
how while I'm sitting there looking at
some of these cards and writing in them
it was like oh I kind of get to live a
little vicariously through these other
dads and their sons relationship because
like a father-son connection that like a
father and a son they're their
individual people and but the connection
between a father and a son is you know
it's its own thing it's its own yarn
it's its own tapestry it's its own
weaving you know if it's if it were a
scarf it would look a certain way a
different color and texture scarf then
one between a mother and a daughter or a
a man and his friend or a boss and his
coworker and I was thinking that it was
kind of cool it was like you know I
don't get to talk to my dad on Father's
Day but I get to be a part of these
other dads and sons and so it made me
think like you know we still we can even
if I can't have something or you can't
have something we can still have that
the joy from it from somebody else you
know like if I know that like a dad left
out of there and he felt like man man it
was nice that that this past weekend had
me come out and and and just have a nice
time and and that they cared it's like I
get to live vicariously through that a
little bit it's like it's not my scarf
between me and my dad it's not my but
it's the same texture it's the same
color it's still that same connection
it's just somebody else's it's almost
like I don't know I don't know I'm
trying to say it's almost like you can
borrow and I get the same feelings from
and I get the same feelings of like of
just knowing that that I'm a part of a
connection like that I don't know if
that makes sense it's just like that
sometimes even if you don't have a
certain connection in your life that we
can borrow that connection from other
people and still have that same joy or
still get some of the same joy so yeah I
was just kind of connection hopping this
week and but it was great somebody just
a lot of a lot of neat guys that came
out and it was just fun and so I want to
thank everybody um through patreon that
I'll help support it and made that and
made that possible oh I'm a little
exhausted but I had a I just had a great
time I was in Boise last night and we
went to get to this Egyptian tit-tit
theater and the Egyptians dude you got
to think about the Egyptians man because
a lot of times I'm laying around the
house and I'll dude I'll go for months
without thinking about the Egyptians I
mean that's just sad
and they did it all dude if you go look
at them they're always they got the
Halloween costumes they got the you know
they're dressed like kind of like
rappers and they're all dressed like a
little bit like Beyonce if she were at
like a um like maybe Beyonce but if if
you know like she was married to like a
fabric
somebody who's like a welder you know
there's a lot they got a lot of statues
they was drinking wine I mean just to
it's sad that I go so long without
thinking about the Egyptians but but I
was at the Egyptian theater and then we
had a couple shows in Portland and
actually a call came in to the hotline
right here for this port from it just
says Portland show so let's check it out
you know brother this is Matt Lowe I
live in the Portland area what's up Matt
over there in Portland and Portland they
say one of the cleanest places in the
world one of the top maybe 50 50 or 60
cleanest places I think that's soap
country boy that is clean country let's
go just wanted to call I went to your
show last night at 7 o'clock
Early Show it was [ __ ] awesome I know
there was some audio issues or something
like that and the bed union was kind of
shitty because they didn't help when
there was one thief drunk and being
crazy and he said it was the first time
this happened on your tour so even
though it's not my fault I don't know
the lady but she definitely was out of
hand
and I know you felt really bad because
you're just a legit guy and everybody
can feel that so I guess I just wanted
to apologize for her because I don't
think she did and and I just felt bad
that that even happened because I know
you're up there trying to entertain us
and she kind of threw off the mood a
little bit and made you feel bad but I
just want to let you know that the show
was [ __ ] amazing well thanks thanks
man for the call yeah I felt bad too you
know that I you know kind of jumped on
her case I mean she just was she just
kept Wootton and hollering and it just
you know I wish somebody would have just
if she was acting like somebody was
tickling her and nobody was and her
husband I think was right there and
he'll I mean he she said she had seven
children so if anybody's tickled or it's
him I will say that you know probably
but by yeah she I felt bad too cuz she
was drunk you know and she and then
she probably wanted to come out and have
a good time and next thing you know
she's back at home just laying in bed
with her husband and thinking like [ __ ]
I already got seven kids so probably
should just go to bed so yeah but that's
nice you too same anyway it was fun it
was fun it was it was like in a
gymnasium oh the cool thing about the
Portland shows so you know after the
show's met some people backstage and
they had it was it's in an old high
school so you're meeting people and
chatting and it's all like these lockers
from high school all of these just
remember that remember when you got the
locker at high school remember the first
time you got a locker I think it was
like fifth grade or seventh grade and
you went up to it and like other kids
knew how to open their lockers but you
didn't cuz this your first time but you
had to act like you knew right because
if somebody saw you not opening your
locker right and I mean this was junior
high you were probably gonna go to hell
so you get up there and you try the code
in your life do one kid I remember
brought this this uh this real skinny
dude that lived by us named Gabe he got
in his locker
and we [ __ ] never saw him again he
just got in there I'm like Gabe what are
you doing dude he said I'm trying to get
some peace and quiet like all right man
you missing math but whatever I remember
you had that locker you opened it up and
there was nothing in there there was
like some gum and it was like some dirt
a little in the bottom or some rust
maybe and you put a book or something in
that [ __ ] close it and never go back to
it that's what I remember
and instead I would just carry like 60
pounds of books on my back all year
round
because it was just hard to get to your
locker and he put some gym clothes in
there those things
[Music]
you-you-you put some I mean some gym
clothes that was real fertile in there
cuz this is seventh grade you guys
seeing you know you have body you sweat
your even your sweat has probably a
little bit of seed in it a little bit of
you Jackie a lot you know so you put a
couple of sweat you know shirts in there
in this couple dirty socks you come back
a month later they got six little socks
running around in there you know put uh
maybe throw a little bit of uh you know
some birdseed or some pine nuts in there
form for snacks
but yeah Locker was crazy he just opened
it up sometimes right like a dirty word
and it tits close it up lose your code
have no idea a couple kids are school
put their books in never even went to
Clyde left school when he got a job
doing construction with their father but
thanks for the call man you know I felt
bad that you know I don't know and look
it's it's a show people come out but the
lady was just so drunk that was the
thing is she just you know I just I felt
a little bit bad for and I don't how to
handle it and I had a long day man I had
a long day we had to go through customs
and all I had to eat was some damn
doughnuts and that [ __ ] I mean you know
quit my Aikido died about two weeks ago
and and I was just you know it's hard
when you crossing the border and all you
got is a couple of you know sugar treats
for yourself let's take another call
here that came in the hotline as always
as nine eight five six six four nine
five two zero three I'm a little bit
exhausted today but the new studio is
coming along good we got this beautiful
paint in here and I'm just so grateful
to my producer Nick and y'all a lot of
y'all know no you know no premature Nick
and he I mean he you know he's been
through a lot and he you know he really
put this place together I mean he paint
I mean this place looks like a damn full
term person that painted it like
somebody that went all nine months bro
but he's an underdog
man he's an underdog that's what we love
here and that's uh that's what we do man
we're working with underdog baby oh
let's take this call by CEO money David
I'm out here in Vancouver Washington
onward gang gang man Vancouver
Washington and that's the tricky thing a
lot of times you get in these coastal
while you get in them you get near these
border areas and they trick you you
think you're in Vancouver uh Canada but
you're only in Vancouver Washington and
you start celebrating and your family's
all excited oh we're in Vancouver you
there for two nights drinking you know
making moonshine or whatever kissing
anybody close doesn't even matter none
even matter how how how well you know
him or how many family photographs of
yours they happen to have been in over
the years and then finally like oh no
you're only in Vancouver Washington it's
like you're in you know oh yeah you're
in a New York City Puerto Rico and
you're like off took a blab took a bad
flight so you got to really pay
attention to maps let's hear more and
you just recently came through Portland
and you issued a request for us to put
in nominations for bad because it's
Father's Day oh yeah man and happy
belated Father's Day to you I nominated
my friend who had sole custody is his
daughter and he raised her from a little
infant and you chose to you chose to
give him tickets he brought me and we
had a great time and my buddy just had
had a blast and we actually got to meet
you at the end of the whole thing we
were the first people in line we just
got treated great and we shook your hand
took some pictures with you and you know
I just wanted to say because I've been
listening for a while and and and I know
you're not the kind of guy who you know
takes well it seems to me I shouldn't
say I know but it just seems to me that
you're not the kind of guy who takes
compliments easily but you've made a
real big difference in
in my life recently and the positivity
that I feel and and gave my buddy and I
are really great it really gave great
gift that that we're gonna remember and
I just wanted to say thank you anyway
you have a great day and everybody else
have a great day too
well thank you for the Coleman it sounds
like that your buddies lucky to have
somebody like you to be honest with you
and I'm glad you guys came in I'm glad
you came and I love you know I love
getting to make I love getting to
perform I love getting to
you know I love getting to do what I
feel like I'm supposed to do sometimes
yeah there's moments when you just know
people are having fun and you see people
and they're just they're having fun you
know and it's what's interesting even
now thinking about it sometimes I wish
that I could be sometimes I wish I was a
better at being the person sitting in
the audience having a good time you know
it does it was always hard for me to be
that I just I don't know that's so crazy
because I was just talking about this at
the beginning of the show and just
thinking about it but yeah it's like he
always had to squeeze the fun out of me
man you always had to like I just I was
afraid to let people see me having fun I
was afraid to almost let my body feel me
having joy having laughter it just
because it was gonna be like such a
foreign thing I never thought that maybe
one of the reasons why I even get up on
stage is because you know when I see
other people having a good time man it
really I just can't explain it to you
like when you see somebody and you see
them and their buddy laughing and and
it's funny cuz sometimes during the so
different people are laughing at
different things one person laughing at
a joke one person laughing at a
reference from the podcast one person's
laugh and you can tell you can tell it a
certain point safe your oh I'm a
stenographer somebody or uh you can tell
or you're a typist or whatever you can
you just know well the buttons are you
can know what's going on out there and
sometimes you can tell oh this person is
laughing for this reason and this person
they saw that and oh this this girl on
the front you kiddin laughed the whole
time but she finally laughed right there
and that maybe that little movement got
her and and looked that person mate you
know they just held their husband's hand
or they're you know they're you know gay
husbands hanging or something and it
just makes you feel good man it makes me
feel I don't know it's like all I always
want to feel okay
and if I can't always feel okay at least
I can I don't know I can't explain it
but I'm trying to but story in my life
but um but do ya man I do I'm just glad
you came out I'm glad you came out and
brought your buddy
you know we don't think about single
dads and I I would forget about my dad
as a single dad I forgot about that you
know I live so much with my mom and my
dad lived in this apartment he lived in
a real like just jacked out Shack that
people jerking off in a yard I remember
we used to watch these guys kind of jerk
off out there or and one guy would
always bury it in the ground you know
after he did it and I don't know and had
people guys would sometimes knock on the
door and ask my dad for money and then
one got stabbed in one time with a
screwdriver
you know and I remember yelling at the
guy you know that's for carpentry that's
for you know that's for carpentry you
know getting pissed man I don't like
when people use things really they're
not supposed to be using for certain
stuff you know like if you see somebody
bathing inside of a boat in their yard I
remember we had these people are on the
street from us
this guy named tip you know like the tip
of something like the end of something
and someone they had a boat over there
and they have friends and sometimes they
would bathe in side of the boat cuz I
guess it was sealed off well enough that
[ __ ] pissed me off dude I don't know why
I just don't like I don't mind it but
for some reason he got me he got me
upset but anyway uh yeah and my I just
remember my father lived in this real
[ __ ] and um and I guess I forgot
what it was like you know over the you
know what being a single dad was like
for him kind of I don't know if he was
stilled I guess he was still dating
because I do remember he met this lady
that made these roast beef sandwiches
God dude this lady the sandwiches were
so good I don't even I don't even know
who she was man the sandwiches was that
good
and she lived in this fancy place man
she lived in this it was like a
high-rise condominium my dad would take
us over there and did we roll over there
and it's dinner Delta 88 and a cutlass
dude then my dad had bought off a couple
brothers and all had speakers in it so
he my dad was had you know some 22s or
28 in the back of this [ __ ] Cutlass
and he couldn't hear well so you know
bass and all that it was nothing to him
but we'd be sitting there just mmm
[Music]
and it was always like oldies moot it's
like oldies music you know Knowles divil
my tutu I'd be like Paul Harvey who was
this old radio host you'd be like Paul
Harvey good good good good D you know he
just had this based out [ __ ] unit and
he would roll us kids over there and the
lady's name was Maggie that was her name
Maggie Zephyr Nick
I just remembered and man she made this
and she had like a the house had high
ceilings in it and the walls were
painted pink and like a nice paint too
not like because rich people have like a
color as a paint that you can't get if
you're poor you know rich people they
have I don't know this paint looked like
a I don't know it look like it was just
made out of just Newt like newborn
female babies like that color just to
that color you see at the hospital that
oh that's the pink for a girl and a blue
for a boy and it was just fancy like
that and because it yeah otherwise do
when your we grow up you get a hot pink
that's the kind of [ __ ] you get hot
green like when you grow up in a in a
regular area boy you get some [ __ ]
hot orange you're like him this [ __ ] is
hot all even though sometimes the colors
you put the jacket on and this [ __ ]
hot but you get that electrics you know
you get that a lot of safety where the
poor you get the more colors your [ __ ]
look like just you know to make you not
get hit by cars at night you ever
noticed that if you real poor you get
the real see that bright bright green
[ __ ] or the bright bright orange you're
like damn they know that person gonna be
out at night and then want to be safe
but this lady had just high ceilings and
she put this pot on the stove and put
some Rose beefin yeah dude I would look
I would be when she started the Rose
beef I would be probably 90 feet away
from the pot four minutes into the roast
beef I would be literally I would have
my face over the meat over the pot just
the steam just getting a
right up just roast-beef facial bridges
my young poor is just just opening up
you just feel I could taste the [ __ ]
roast beef through the walls of my cells
in my cheeks I wanted that roast beef
smoke to just fester inside of my
[ __ ] jowls boy yet I could have
spitted dude I mean I could have spent a
sick sense roast beef sub right I mean I
could have just I could have spit one
off the balcony there was just this [ __ ]
was just forming in my mouth I could
feel it and when that stuff was done we
would sit there man and eat the roast
beef sandwiches man they were good and
we felt like the richest people ever and
we would go sit outside on the balcony
and she had this big balcony I was like
on the 12th floor is fancy right by the
Mississippi River and we will watch the
tug boats go by man we would just make
up things that were on them you know
shoes tallit tisha you know all kinds of
things that had come down from up north
you know caramel my dad used to always
tell us that they was bringing a lot of
caramel from up there in Pennsylvania
and pin Hershey up there and chokolate
and on these big ships and just sitting
there thinking that there was big ships
of you know just of caramel and nougat
dude I remember you see a couple smaller
boats a little nougat shuttles and I'm
just in my head I just was so excited
boy just thinking about a big chocolaty
vessel inna and a nougat barge and then
a couple of you know or a caramel barge
and a couple nougat shuttles just
skipping across the water it really
tickled my sugar bones it was fun though
man
but yeah my dad only had nine fingers
did I do remember that and so every time
he would tickle me he would say I'm not
I'm not I couldn't be tickling you that
good because you only got nine fingers
and so he did really kind of you did
trick me a little I'm a new tell you
this let's take another call here we go
I feel this is Ali calling from Dubai
what's up Ali from Dubai and I am gonna
try to get over there to see Dustin
Poirier fight and I gotta ask Joe Rogan
for a ticket because I don't have any
ticket but I'm gonna see to see him
fight over there against kabhi kabhi
Matta Newman the guarantor all right I
heard you might be coming to Dubai for
the UFC event in September oh there we
go yes sir I might man so uh I'll
probably have to look you up if I do
let's hear more I already have my ticket
so hopefully we can see you there and I
just had a little idea for you I'm a
slim and I thought it might be a good
opportunity for you to learn more about
the flim out in Dubai that come from all
over the world Gang Gang and he's
talking about Muslims and uh recently
coined the term Slim's and it's kind of
like a code name for Muslims let's hear
more thank you for the invitation I
don't know if you have any friends that
are slims but this might be a good
chance for you to make some and I have a
proposition I mean you could stay in a
hotel pay $300 a night they got a
check-in they got a mint on your pillow
but come on you know you really want to
do that you could say other listeners
how it such as myself and learn about
the Flynn life I mean we got lots of
space for you we got an extra room
queen-size bed Wi-Fi your own bathroom
we even got a live-in Filipino mate ooh
well you definitely sweetening the deal
there was probably my favorite ethnicity
in the entire universe that I've met
which is Filipinos the happy people dude
if you crack a Filipino open bro all
that's inside sheer joy sheer joy God's
pinatas brother that's what I call them
they're the happiest people in the
universe I like this I like this
proposition man uh let's hear more to
iron your t-shirts and make you eggs in
the morning we got a pool we got a
basketball whoo
my kids got scooters and just so you
know the think of any kind of home owner
situation I got to
white hahaha okay well Manuel look I'll
tell you this if I go to the fight I'll
come and stay for a night man you got me
hooked dude I would love to learn more
about the slim life man and you know
what's funny is man I do need to know
more about Muslim culture because I
don't really know that much about it you
know I just I think I just have like
some perceptions and I don't really like
I don't have any like anger or disdain
towards you no I don't think like Muslim
like I have like anger this day and if I
think of like you know Isis or Taliban
type people are like you know or
basically extremists from anywhere
really but a lot of people including
myself get you know they get the term
Muslim it's like well what is it they
get it confused I get it mixed up so I
think that'd be a great opportunity for
me man I appreciate you offering that
dude that's really nice of you and and
it's so funny actors as soon as I find
out I'll let you know
dude the eggs bro the eggs alone a
couple Filipino eggs dude I'm in this is
like what's that movie where they find
those Filipino eggs and it had a
mosquito in it Jurassic Park unless
you're not offering them up like any
kind of Hollywood thing I'm just letting
you know what the situation is so it's
an open offer there's nothing weird just
the place is safe I'll learn a little
learn a little bit more about goodbye in
the flim life while you're here slim
life bro I love it man yeah dude you
look man I'll be your slim dog
millionaire dude I'm excited so if I go
I'll make sure that we save this and
that we reach out and that's sweet of
you man I appreciate the opportunity and
and what to find it you know if we do
we'll find a way to to uh to return the
favor
yeah I can't even a matte like it's
funny if I do think about Dubai I think
like what is it like you know what's
going on over there so that's one of the
main reasons I mean obviously I would
love to see the fight even though I'll
get a little bit scared at the fights
but I think it would be great to go and
just see kind of just what that
environment is like over there because I
can't even imagine I mean I really can't
even imagine I did some military tours
that were like Saudi Arabia and Iraq or
Iraq Iraq but but I've never been in a
place that wasn't like a military or
like which contractors
in the Middle East I've never been just
like willy-nilly out and about so that's
sweet of you brother she ate you man so
many nice people you know when most of
people are are just nice people they
really are it's one thing I noticed I
was driving across you know we drew we
drove across a little bit of a good bit
of the Pacific Northwest maybe about
eight hours or something this weekend
and man America is a beautiful country
it really really is and it's just
beautiful up there if you've never been
just you know you're driving along
between Seattle and Portland and there's
just all these beautiful trees and
outlooks and Mount Helena's in the
background or not Helena's mount st.
Helens I think and dude I'll tell you
this I got beat in fifth grade in a
spelling bee by a pregnant girl named
Halina King so you know who knows what
can happen but uh let's read something
else man I'll tell you this oh I'll tell
you what can happen is you got to clean
your body you got to clean your body a
little you got to clean around your
booty to around you a little dirt
circuit you know what I'm talking about
polish up your dirt circuit and how do
you do that but delegates natural
cleansing foam brings you the luxury and
elegance of of a day with the
convenience of toilet paper and I've
been using toilet paper my whole life I
think you know I don't know if I was
real young if I didn't I mean dude we
had a little guy in our neighborhood he
wouldn't uh I'll tell you about him he
wouldn't wipe his butt and he wouldn't
wipe his butt as long as I knew
and he always was itching his butt oh it
made me so sick and sad he was always
hitch in his butt and so then it was
like dude get out here and he would
always try to tickle you as well
and I don't like that man if somebody's
you know if somebody's got a bunch of
duty on you know like they've been
touching their butt and they try to
tickle you that's do a silly
that's silly to me to me and I'm not
saying it has to be to you that's just
my perception but but delegates is that
natural foam cleanser that natural
cleaning foam brings you the luxury and
elegance of a bidet with the convenience
of tallit paper they got that hitter
right there that bottle but elegance
applied elegance moisturizing cleansing
foam the toilet paper and two wet clean
and dry your private areas so you can
clean your privets baby you know what
I'm saying you could trim your hedges
maybe you could tighten up that dirt
circuit both front and back ladies - go
on brush it bodies off bud elegance
better than both dry toilet paper and
wet wipes it's cost-effective
anti-inflammatory soothing keeps your
hands dry here is a reviewer from Amazon
Marissa five out of five stars three and
a quarter stars
sorry that's from an old TV show Marissa
five out of five elegance I purchased
this product due to Theo von
recommending this to me on his podcast
this past weekend he said that if I
couldn't afford a bidet this would be
the next best option and I can't afford
a bidet I currently rent my residence
and I don't think my landlord or the HOA
would be happy with me installing one
plus my bathroom is tiny and I would not
have anywhere to put it unless I pulled
out the shower maybe hot it's awesome
and crazy
you can't get rid of the showers to do
that anyway
I am cleaner than ever thanks but
elegance and Theo von you can get bit
elegance now right now on amazon.com and
and get 10% off and free shipping using
code 1-0 Theo von that's the number 10
Theo von
all in one word 1 0 th EO vo in for 10%
off and free shipping using 10 Theo von
that's at amazon.com but elegance bi de
le g ance tighten up your dirt circuit
let's take another call hey Theo this is
Mike from Northern Illinois I what's up
Mike from Northern Illinois dude I love
Illinois you know I really love it my
mother grew up there and um and I love
it you know let's hear more had twins
last weekend
Oh congratulations you just had twins
man you got two of them ah well I had
twins come on to one of the shows this
week and you guys know how I feel about
it is
they should really kind of just have one
of them around I mean let's I mean I
shouldn't say that because these are
newborns let me hear more brother onward
one boy want a girl okay well that's a
little different if you get two boys or
two girls I think you gotta make them
fight if it's babies three and four we
tried for a third be out of force the
reason I'm calling is I have a question
for you oh yeah baby
you won't three you'll get four the Lord
does math brother the Lord does math do
a little bit of a dilemma with with the
wife now she wants to formula feed the
reason why she doesn't want to keep
pumping is because when they get home
she wants both of us to wake up in the
middle of a night to feed him with
bottles and I said keep pumping then and
I'll wake up with her I'll get a bottle
will used to be the baby you know I
understand that but her dilemma is that
she has to wake up every three hours to
pump in the middle of the night
regardless because you know entities get
full of milk oh yeah man that's the
[ __ ] your wife turns into a damn
leche Chevron brother hey Suze Christ oh
man damn your wife whoo she got to
really pump them tats out more they
gotta be pumped like a farm animal so I
proposed the idea that while she's
sleeping I could hook up her breast pump
to her nipples and milk her like a farm
animal as he's sleeping now he's not on
board oh yeah that's called siphoning
and we used to do that sometime we sneak
around the around the neighborhood and
steal radios out of people's cars and
siphoned gas out of their tank and then
uh and we all worked at a children's
care center and we all got laid off
actually let's hear more and I need your
help to convince her that this is our
best solution because formula is $400 a
month Jesus dude where are you getting
it from Iran bro you got to get that
local sip papa
hmm dude I know a lady will [ __ ] give
you a whole Titsworth for [ __ ]
probably six dollars or whatever a
little can how much is it
I got to look it up formula dude how
guys go to look up formula and just
enough watching races on YouTube and
Europe okay let's hear more uh yeah man
uh homework for two babies now I can do
a lot of $400 so I would rather just you
know no time nipples and uh that's been
at mine formula bro here's the thing you
deposited seed in your wife buddy okay
she didn't outsource that you know she
took your milk she took that hit you
know that but you know that conditioner
that you know that little that wiener
you know that little wiener sipper she
absorbed that for you and she tanked you
out too little you know too little bad
ones too little eggs so you got to show
up and do your [ __ ] man you know you got
to show up and do your [ __ ] man if you
got a couple of kids out there you got
to feed them run now if I had twins what
I do I've always wanted to do this teach
one kid the full alphabet teach another
kid only half of the alphabet and then
if as the one kid gets older every now
and then for their birthday you give
them an extra letter you tell them about
a new letter that exists that they don't
know about so you know so you teach them
half the alphabet to a through m and
then when they're nine years old you
give them L for their birthday how
amazing that suddenly a whole new world
ladder parallel lollipop all these new
things to them you know or that or L
comes before M so you have to give them
in or you give them o or you give you no
I'm saying you give them a couple
letters for their birthday that way you
you know you saving money like that so
that might be a different thing maybe
think of other ways to save money do
don't chirp on your wife right now you
know or get your aunt to give a little
bit of breast milk dude I remember we
used to take a [ __ ] hit off the
neighbors Ted every now and then if mom
was running like
and look you know I'm a rat you know
I've always had a little bit of that
anxiety you know because my mother had
small breasts you know they may they may
have coops babies and makeups and so
it's hard for a baby to get that milk
out of a egg cup I mean all right
nothing if you ever see a baby kind of
just he looks like he's from Jamaica he
might just be true you know like that
cat on the internet that's part that's
that's you know being a um a
receptionist you know you'll see a baby
trying to beat the milk out of that
breast because an a-cup don't have much
in it so you get that anxiety you know
you get that tit that that that uh you
get that tit twitch because you're not
you know you're trying to I mean my
mother every now and then you get a sip
you don't fill up on her on them you
know if your mother have a small breast
and that anxiety that rattle you know
that tit rattle that small tit rattle
that you know that stays in you forever
if your mother got small tit you always
have anxiety because you never got that
full luscious hitter yet I remember
seeing other babies and they would have
[ __ ] milk just all down their neck
you know they had baby spray and milk
out of their moms tits in the air at the
strip club and Here I am over here just
trying to beat another sip out of this
thing like God you know like a guy at
the boxing gym like um Peter Manfredo
jr. you know just trying to beat another
one more you know good mom had them
small breasts you don't get you know say
well I'm always gonna have that anxiety
of I'm missing something
oh let's take another call here but
first I want to tell you that if you are
struggling with uh with some mental
health issues and it's okay if you are
you know I forgot my medicine this
weekend
I forgot my antidepressants and I take
them and man I don't want to take them
anymore
you know I'm tired you know I'm tired of
taking them I'm tired of not having some
of my feelings but I'm not gonna get off
them right now and I'm not going to get
off them suddenly so I have to make a
plan to get off them people always send
me messages hey man
get off the antidepressants well that's
fine brother you get off them okay you
do what you want to do with them okay
but I'm scared to get off them right now
so I can't just stop you know it's hard
to do and I want to do it but I have to
do in a moun timeframe but this company
is called better help calm and they have
professional and affordable counseling
you can get matched up with counselors
that are right for you better help calm
has for communication modes text chat
phone and video mode start communicating
under 24 hours you must be 18 I have
used better help okay I've got another
you get connected with your counselor
you can communicate with them over text
if you having a tough time you can call
them on the phone and do a session you
can pull over on the side of the road
and do a video chat right there with
your therapist you can find one that
works for you if you don't want to go to
an office or you don't have that
opportunity where you are but you still
feel like you could use some help this
is an option that's all this is I'm just
letting you know that it's available
worldwide it's not intended for those
actively considering suicide it's
available on desktop mobile web Android
and iOS you can send messages 24/7 365
easy to change counsellors financial aid
is available sign up at better help calm
slash Theo today that's better help calm
slash Theo th EO today let's take a
question from our patreon that came in
sorry from this doing a bunch of
questions today man I am a little bit
beat
but we got a fun week I mean we have a
fun week of some episodes we're doing to
King and the sting episodes tomorrow and
I'm excited to see Bernie's shopman hey
that guy always makes me laugh so I'm
excited about that here's a question
that came in ki Jenkins this person's
name ki Jenkins qie Jenkins and this is
from one of our patreon people it says
you are always talking negative about
your sexual experiences do you have a
memorable positive sexual experience and
it's a good question man you know I got
into a threesome sexual experience one
time that was pretty interesting you
know and I guess that was gratifying in
some ways because it was like you know
it felt like sometimes you give her been
to a petting zoo you have you know one
animals over by this rail and you go
touch them one animals over there and
dude sometimes at a petting zoo you'll
see some kid petting the animals wiener
you know you'll see a three-year-old
just reach through thing he don't even
know you know I remember one time being
over there at the Audubon zoo over there
in New Orleans watching a [ __ ] some
three-year-old kid just hand muggin
uh-uh-uh-uh-uh-uh one of those out
pakka's or no I don't think it's a now
pack of mothers in a pack is that a bird
yeah it wasn't a Oh what is that Jesus
Christ dude I think was like a white
Walker um it wasn't a bison on what the
[ __ ] was that thing with the big horns I
don't know but I said you know you see a
little toddler over there he's just
trying to touch a hand while he's
reaching through and next thing you know
he's you know he's playing a highest
hand on an animal's wiener with somebody
else on accident you never know but each
usually you buy each rail they got a
different animal you
this one in pet this one and that one
and if you're more engaged in a
threesome activity than you you know you
could be all the animals are right by
you at once but these girls didn't
really know each other I mean they knew
each other I didn't know them and they
said that they were cousins and one of
them kind of looked on like a real
strong strong like person from like
Poland or something from like maybe
maybe a hundred years ago and and the
other girl was real she was cool and
stuff but she also wore a backpack the
whole time while we were hooking up so I
don't [ __ ] know man that wasn't that
good I guess to have a memorable
positive sexual experience you know I
think I mean I enjoy sexual experiences
but I really have never really felt that
comfortable to be honest with you you
know I feel ashamed of things that I
might be interested in sexually
sometimes or that I think about you know
for some reason I have a lot of shame
around a lot of that all that kind of
stuff you know just really even just
talking about right now - I just feel
very ashamed of myself
so I don't know if I've had really that
good of an experience a memorable
positive sexual experience oh and I
don't know I mean when I was young as
girl you know I was I was really into
this girl and she was trying to you know
she was like a girlfriend of mine and
she tried to give me a little law you
know a little blow job a little bit of
oral a little bit of oral outside of uh
at a party behind his big pine tree in
them one of the moms caught us
and I remember dude the moms like what
are you all doing right and the craziest
thing I didn't know what to say right
and I just said having a little bit of
dessert that's what I said and the girl
was the one giving me to [ __ ]
and I didn't even mean it like a joke I
was just trying to lie because it was a
birthday party I knew this cake and the
other you know in the other area where
people are eating in a carport like what
are y'all doing over here in us just
having a little bit of dessert
meanwhile this girl's giving me a blow
job or trying her best and also we were
both young so you can't the girls trying
her best to give a [ __ ] she barely
neither one of us barely knows what
we're doing
you know she's giving me a [ __ ] I'm
praying that it is a [ __ ] I don't
even know what's going on so here's
another one that came in Michelle
Mildred I'm a newly single mom little
baby born three weeks ago the paternal
side the male side decided not to be
involved as someone raised by a single
mom what advice would you give me
[Music]
you know the the thing I'm noticing most
about being a child and being an adult
is that kids can never tell you the
things I don't think that you wish they
could or here's what I hear here's what
I'm thinking more feeling more I can
never like I wish I could go back in
time and tell my parents what I want to
tell him when I was then you know I wish
I could've told my mom when I was young
that I did I wish she didn't have to
work so hard so that you know and I wish
that I could just help her to feel
better and I wish I could just you know
just that everything was gonna be okay
you know I wish I could just you know
and so funny I was filling out some of
those Father's Day cards and just right
in a moment I say filling them out but
just writing intamin and it was funny
because some of the messages that were
in there I was like oh these are things
that I wish I could tell my dad you know
so I think some of that I think you
ought you may never hear from your kid
what what you want to hear from them
until later on in life that's what it
seems like to me you may not hear from
them later on in life and but just be
patient you know because they're trying
to learn to while you're trying to learn
and maybe try to try and let them have a
world that's like a safe place where
they don't know about everything they're
already gonna learn so much with the
internet and with social media and
everything try and see if you can have a
world with them where they don't have to
have all that immediately and just try
to have it try to laugh with them
you know and don't and and they can have
fatherly figures from other places and
try to cultivate that you know be aware
of it that maybe some men might be
dangerous people or touchers or
something but some men might be decent
people you know who aren't trying to
touch your kid and don't make that kid
be like you know let him get into some
stuff it's okay he's gonna be okay you
know he's durable you know
[Music]
and ask him how he feels about stuff you
know nobody ever asked me how I felt and
so I didn't know if I was even allowed
to feel and I and then I thought started
to think that my feelings were just
these things inside of me that were
wrong or that were uncomfortable or that
I just didn't know what they were so
those would be some things that I think
might be neat let's take two more calls
right here what our CEO
this is Nathan from Nashville Tennessee
was listening to podcasts for a long
time now man and I know your dad had you
when you were like 7b or when he was
like 70 so I was wondering are you
wanting kids eventually in the future
the only reason I asked man is because
I'm I'm 31 and I'm kind of trying to
figure out you know do I want a child or
not you know I think my big problem is I
don't have a phobia of having a child
with the wrong lady
no because whether you like to believe
it or not you're attached to that person
for at least 18 years you know the girl
so I kind of want to make sure it's
right you know before I have before I
bring a child into this world
I love the podcast and listening to it
forever getting gang and r.i.p Billie
conforto oh man yeah RI pbilic afford to
man thank you for saying that you know I
was just thinking about him the other
day do not think I was on some sohmas
one time and you might have tried to
kiss me one time but I'm also not sure
about that but um but anyway I'm
thinking my putting some shirts up that
really comfort for TOI shirts and then
maybe we could surprise his mother with
some of them if we may raise some money
from it or donate the money to dogs I
know he really loved dogs let me say
this man I think about that too it's
funny you say you're scared about and
it's funny say you're scared about
having with the wrong person
you know it's like how much wish there
was an app where it's like do you want
to have kids I want to have kids and
just co-parenting and now I know that
you're not gonna maybe have the same
bond of a home where the payment where
you know you have that you know the same
connection if the parents aren't like if
there's not that maybe if the parents
don't have a sexual chemistry or a love
that kind of loving if the kids don't
see that will that make the kid back you
know be raised a certain way I don't
know but but yeah it's a big concern but
it's at least you're thinking about that
some people just roll right into it
don't think about it you know they just
skied out into something soft over there
next thing you know they're fist
fighting on Maury but at least you're
thinking about that I wish there was an
app where you could say you know I want
a co-parent that deaf I because
sometimes it's like you meet somebody
like oh they would be the perfect other
parent you know I'm not sexually really
attract I don't have the same sexual
attraction to them or I'm unable to be
in a committed relationship but I would
still maybe love to we could have a
child together and raise that child
lovingly now what an issue you run into
the end though also is a religious issue
a lot of people they want to keep you
know when there's a lot of religion
based it's hard for them to bend some of
those rules and and and my only thought
to that would just be that if it's a
loving enough space that I think your
higher power would understand you know
if a if a husband and a wife aren't
married but if they you could still live
together you could still say look this
is my the mother of my child or the
mother of my children I'm the father of
her children I'm the father of her child
and we lived together and we're great
parents she dates she has a maybe a
dating life and I have maybe one but you
know I had a friend a few years ago and
we made a pact that if neither one of us
got married by a certain age we would
have a child together because we loved
being around each other and and we
thought we could be good parents and
loving parents
and she ended up meet you know met
somebody and got married and I'm so
happy for and she has a couple kids now
and but I think it's worth figuring out
you know I think it's worth thinking
about some of it like you are because
raising children is important and
raising people to be good people and
cutting off some of these bad habits and
these dark arts that are getting into us
all I don't know I might be something
like a little preachy and know-it-all
I'm feeling kind of high-strung
sometimes when I get high-strung I get I
turned into a know-it-all and I really
hate that about myself but that's a
great question you know and we could put
that out to the listeners too what do
you guys think hit the hotline with some
suggestions for this young man let's
hear the question one more time having a
child with the wrong lady
no because whether you like to believe
it or not you're attached to that person
for at least 18 years you know the girl
so I kind of want to make sure it's
right you know before I have before I
bring a child into this world
I love the podcast yeah he wants to make
sure it's right
does it have to be a relationship that
is you know if some of you guys have
been divorced would you go back and do
it different it does it have to be what
a co-parenting type of situation work
those are just you know you can field
some of those thoughts and hit the
hotline nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three and we'll put a
couple of the answers on next week's
episodes or a couple of the suggestions
but I don't know man I think the only
suggestion that I have is because I
don't have any children but I think
about it but it's also very scary to me
because I don't want to turn into
somebody you know I don't want to end up
not doing something you know you know I
don't I don't think I'd be a bad dad but
I don't want to end up getting selfish
or something and doing you know
something that makes my kid feel bad and
then I'm not a good parent you know and
then our relationship is messed up or
something you know you know I mean like
you know if I you know I cheated on my
wife or if I rant you know like I just I
don't know all that kind of stuff really
spooks me out you know about having just
I think just having that commitment
having a full commitment of a child and
maybe that's selfish and that's if it is
selfish I'm not saying that it isn't you
know I might just be being selfish I
don't know but I think it's nice that
people are thinking about this instead
of just out there busting them so gang
bro let's hear one more one more call
that came in and thanks thank you so
much a lot of people brought me some
nice gifts this weekend a young lady
brought me a beautiful Rat King art and
man it's nice art man is nice young
fellow who's too young fellows in
military brought me a 50 Cal bullet so
that was pretty caught never even seen
that thing is bang yeah if you get hit
by that boys it's it's lights out
you better call Entergy because it's
lights out whoo and then what else a
couple of other nice things man a book a
gentleman gave me about clavicles it
because you know I got them see babies
up here and man I know I'm forgetting a
couple things and I'm sorry about that
it's nothing personal and some cards and
stuff and I know a lot of times I don't
mention all those things but I do want
to say thank you you know and they're
nice things and sometimes I bring them
back here when we keep in the studio
oh if somebody gave me a thing out of
made out of animal Duty it's like a wolf
patty or something and it's got this
past weekend kind of chiseled into it so
I mean they're chiseling our name in the
[ __ ] so we've really we must be doing
something good Atos James from Flint
Michigan what's up James and my locos
over there daddy long neck is over there
man so Gang Gang in DLN will be outed on
the show in Detroit but thank you for
calling in James onward my relationship
advice is for a longtime best friend I
had growing up I grew up in Chicago
me and him were real good friends he'd
always be kind of a little [ __ ] though
okay
oh we're always talking smack kind of
but then standing behind me what want me
to fight his fights oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's fun to do that homework and
lately ever since I lived in Michigan I
always feel like I'm trying to talk to
them or make plans to hang out but it's
just not reciprocated I don't know man I
just don't know what I should do I was
just calling to hear your thoughts
every time I I try and make plans say
hey man you want to hang out a longtime
best friend new um send for your kids
first time first friend even invited
them to be the best man in the wedding
didn't show up so I don't know man just
uh wondering what your thoughts are
about that what would you do Ganga thank
you for calling yeah it sounds like you
might be a stalker you know if you keep
you know holler at your boy and he's
showing up and he ain't reciprocating it
sounds like is this even your friend man
you know is this somebody you just knew
is this somebody you've seen on the
Internet
that's really a question you have to
really consider for yourself you know
overall but also you know I think about
this you know I have friends sometimes I
call my friends I feel like a lot and
they don't call me I feel like as much
and that's okay you know and some of
them probably feel the same way about me
some of them probably feel like oh I
call him a lot you don't call me much
and
you know
the thing is is that you could cut off
your friend you could say ah well this
guy and and somewhere inside of you
he'll get cut off naturally a little bit
more and more as you guys distance from
each other but every time you reach out
to him it's not a weakness man it's not
a thing like that it's really you never
know dude maybe that one time that he
really needs somebody and you're the
freaking you know and yeah you're that
you know you're DTF do you're down to
friend and you're down to friend man and
you you know it's so he might not
reciprocate but you just never know like
what the bigger plan is there there may
be this bigger plan in the world where
you got a call you know you got to keep
pestering him and one day finally you
know or one day he's in like you just
don't know what you're being used for
you might be you might be needing to
help him out he might not need a friend
today but it might be six months for now
when he does need it and since you
didn't give up on him he's you know
you're still gonna be there and he may
never say thank you for it but but
you'll know you know you'll know that
there was a purpose for doing all of
that but he had only driving by his
house and [ __ ] at night dude I used to
get jealous man when I was growing up my
best friend is boy Scott sach field and
I mean this kid was damn beautiful you
know you and they knew he was beautiful
a couple of towns over you know I
remember you put your ear to the stream
up from down up the stream coming from
up north and the stream would know the
stream would just right past year just
Scott's beautiful was like what the [ __ ]
everybody knows it you know and he was
just a handsome kid he's much handsomer
then I'll ever be in my life right and
all the girls liked him you know at
lunchtime I was the one they would give
me all of the notes to take to him so
it's like [ __ ] man I was basically the
May I was a mailman
and uh and then it's kind of cool
because you're involved a little bit but
then at the end your does you know you
just said all the Valentine's you just
get to touch him you don't get to open
them up and then one time this kid also
lives in our County Ian Somerhalder and
he was a vampire he's like a famous
vampire now a beautiful man and this
dude was the hottest man or woman that
ever lived in our town either one dude
this dude I mean he was if you looked at
him he was so high he just you saw tits
that's how hot he was you're like he saw
bikinis you saw everything he was just
and uh and they became friends at one
point when I was a kid they became
friends and man I was so upset dude
because I hated the way I looked so much
I couldn't have ever competed with them
you know I was just couldn't have ever
done it you know I just didn't have any
but anyway my friend Scott and I we
patched things up you know it was fifth
grade sixth grade but then years later
we went for like a year without talking
we just went our separate ways for a bit
and then we came back together and these
days were really close and it's like
sometimes you just don't know like the
path of friendship and sometimes when
other people are letting us down the
thing where you have to try and do even
though it's hard to just be loving
it's just be loving instead of being
holding that grudge or and it's hard man
am I saying that I'd do it but I do I
feel a lot of times like it's the right
thing to do so just keep calling them
and keep checking in I saw that's
probably what I would do honestly I mean
but yeah they'll be hiding in the dudes
book bag and [ __ ] when he goes to us
home when he goes to to does homework
you pop out and [ __ ] dude that's illegal
so but yeah you never know when
somebody's gonna come along and try to
get the fields out of you you know every
some some people you know you might be
the one trying to squeeze the fun out of
your buddy maybe he never wants to do
anything and then one day he's gonna be
like I want to do something that I want
to have some fun you're gonna [ __ ]
call him bro and y'all gonna be out
there at a Goo Goo Dolls concert so
anything anything is possible and that's
what I'm saying what your daddy bear as
he you can you never know you might be
the force that squeezing out somebody's
fun so don't take your fingers off their
ribs bro
you know just hold the line you can do
it and years from now he might return
the favor just we don't know sometime
with the bigger you know why they're at
why everything's getting put in the soup
because it's gonna taste different years
later we just we don't we don't know
that in our mouth yet
but thank you guys for being patient
with me this weekend congratulations
again to those underdog Toronto Raptors
to the whole country of Canada it's
exciting and it's inspiring man it's
it's inspiring if do those people were
so excited I was in Vancouver and they
were they weren't flipping over cars but
people were like they were doing the
Canadian version that they were calling
ubers and then canceling them yeah you
know like in the US will flip over a car
burn down an orphanage but up there they
were they would call ubers and then
cancel them so it got wild but thank you
to everyone who came out this past
weekend to the shows we had a great time
thank you to everybody who supports this
podcast we got some great guests coming
up I think Jordan Belfort the wolf of
Wall Street will be in here soon who
else is on the docket Amanda Knox from
the famous murder who else we got we're
trying to get Lavar ball in here that
big mixed Chatty Cathy so we'll see what
we can do man but um but underdogs
underdogs always man you guys be good to
yourself I bet that you deserve it
[Music]
the song is making it a bishop gun made
of dollar night spell but where it's
going in Cuba yet I still get wet on the
go
we're lucky to be alive man this is it
this is life
[Music]
they can making good time
you know don't be too hard on yourself
we can do this
[Music]
there's nothing wrong with you most all
of my plans slip right through my hand
Wow
[Music]
I'm saying that to you and I'm saying
that to me
[Music]
dang
but how
I'll bet
[Music]
making good
Oh
[Music]
but
[Applause]
[Music]
I hate seen old men powerful to date I
can almost hear mama cream from our
recipes
[Music]
Oh